hi there my name is reto Meier and I'm
usually joined on the app clinic by
Ernie Lewis but the preparation for this
week's show required us to do some
intense physical exercise in order to
properly test personal fitness apps
endomondo runtastic and RunKeeper we
chose to test these apps hiking now back
in Australia we call hiking walking but
folks in California seem to be more
inclined to drive if they're going
anywhere further than the nearest car
park but in any case the last time I saw
Ian was deep in the backwoods of the Big
Basin National Park anyway
find out what features and technical
tips and trips tricks it takes to make a
killer personal fitness app today on the
App clinic so one of the big benefits of
living in the Bay Area is that nearly
there there's a really a little a
limitless supply of hiking trails all
within a really short Drive now being a
certified practicing geek the only thing
more fun than hiking through the
wilderness is tracking my route while
doing so so all three of today's apps
will let me do that and a few other
things as well so all three of today's
apps support a standard set of
functionality which is what I've put up
here now they're all designed to allow
you to a track or workout and in this
case they're optimized for something
running related basically any exercise
which can be measured through a
combination of the distance you've
traveled and the amount of time it's
taken now accordingly they measure the
duration of your workout on the distance
traveled and use that to work out things
like your pace average speed calories
burned water consumed all those sorts of
things and they also use the GPS
information that they track throughout
your workout to display your route on a
map and each of the each of the apps
shows a slightly different set of
details on the map and in fact in terms
of your workout and I'll go through each
of those as we look at the apps in a
little more detail
they each also allow you to select the
activity that you're doing and choose
from a selection of different workouts
so that could be running jogging rowing
cycling push-ups whatever you like and
there's different styles of workouts as
well so it can be a one-off a time trial
versus your friends any any number of
different workout styles and again I'll
show you what some of these apps have to
as we go through them in detail so
taking these features as a baseline you
know as a given this is basically what
your personal fitness tracking app needs
to have in order to be you know in the
game let's take a look at some of the
features that can really help
differentiate those apps from their
competitors so this is my wish list of
things that I'd like to see in personal
fitness apps so there's a bunch of stuff
on this list that's totally in the
nice-to-have territory so things like a
rich tablet experience and analytics the
sort of thing that can really lift an
app well beyond as competitors well
beyond sort of what you would expect
from an app which is really going to
help you win over fans win over users
which you're going to be coming back to
your app and really become addicted to
it but let's face it these features are
the sorts of things which people aren't
going to notice straight away they're
going to require a certain amount of
discovery now why is that important well
as it happens I was hiking in Rancho San
Antonio a couple of weeks ago when my
wife asked me if there was a way that we
could track how far we were going and
how long we would be hiking for and I
thought you know what there's probably
some apps to help with that so I jump
straight on to our suggestions on the
Trello board and install the first three
apps that that were there and that is in
fact the three asset which we're looking
at today now the factors that I use to
decide which app we were going to
actually keep running was how quickly it
let me get started with the confidence
that it was going to record everything
that I wanted it to so a quick start up
and in an intuitive dare I say obvious
controls were really critical so the
overall look and feel were really
important here as well I opened each app
and literally spent five seconds looking
at each of them before I chose which one
I was going to go with so that gives you
a really good idea of just how important
it is to make that great first
impression you know I'm not alone in the
way that I look at my ass people will
just download them and figure well which
of these three am I going to use this
one kind of looks like it's the best so
they're going to go with it so in the
end for me I ended up choosing endomondo
so they've got a beautiful feature page
here which has a perfectly distinctive
icon now it doesn't necessarily say too
much about the app but it's it's quite
clear that you're not going to mistake
that icon for anything else anyone
else's icon
and it fits in really nicely into their
bigger logo as well so it's a really
good example so we really got off onto
the right foot here I looked at this and
thought this this looks legit this looks
like an app that people have spent a
little bit of time and effort on so
let's say let's jump ahead here so when
you open up the app what you get is this
really well designed homescreen
it's totally intuitive it leaves me with
absolutely no question as to what I need
to do to get started
there's a giant green start button that
draws your attention straightaway
and there's a great example of when and
how to create custom controls within
your app the rest of the app looks
pretty standard they've got a clean
white design with a standard action bar
and what I really like about this design
is its simplicity the layout isn't
cluttered you have three pieces of
information about your workout visible
at any time along with the exercise that
you're planning to do in the workout
style that you're planning to engage in
there's even a hint of the map poking
out along the bottom corner and if I
switch to the giant phone I can show you
a couple of other nice features of the
app all right giant phone excellent so
if we uh I'm gonna switch the other side
here because my cables aren't long
enough so if I fire up in demondo you
can see here that if we don't choose not
to go pro so I didn't install the pro
version here simply because I didn't use
the pro version when I was using the app
on the road I'm gonna try and unplug
this and plug it back in hopefully all
will stop flickering or it'll go away in
tirely one of the two there we go still
flickering
hmm what do you think Daniel anything we
can do here or just persevere why don't
you know why don't you persevere for a
second I'm gonna see if actually gonna
go right over there and cut a head mess
with the connection really quick just
give me ten seconds sure I will talk and
I'm gonna stand in front of the giant
and it's gonna be pretty annoying but
nonetheless um what you'll find in fact
if I jump a step back that's gonna make
it easier for us and if you want to just
switch that off for a second so you can
see it straight away that the the layout
isn't clustered and what we've got here
is alongside each of the of the options
on the screen you can see that there's a
little drop-down which is in fact going
to allow you it gives you a hint that
clicking on any of them is actually
going to to do something it's going to
let you choose your options differently
and this is really useful because
straightaway it gives me hints as to how
I'm going to be able to use this app in
the right way so straight away sort of
you know that clicking on stuff is going
to you give me options to change things
and then in fact that's exactly how it
works and so if I click on any of those
options what I get straight away is a
list of alternative things that I can
look at so whether that be looking at
calories consumed rather than distance
traveled or any of those sorts of
options and the same thing goes for the
workout style on the workout activity
that I'm planning to do you know right
away you're able to choose you know
click the drop-down and see oh actually
I'm rolling and when I click on those I
actually get nice big fullscreen
activities rather than pop-ups and this
is kind of important because it makes it
really simple for me to be able to to be
able to make those choices without being
overly distracted which is really really
useful and that's really the way that
the whole UI design for the app works is
that is it is that it's you know it's
really intuitive it's really fast to get
started which is a real benefit so I'm
going to spin this around
we hold it real tight gets yeah I think
it's the movement on the device a little
bit you know it's the issues with MHL so
if there are any miracast
om is out there that are producing
products which are miracast compatible
get on it so we can start using Nexus 4
to do our demos exactly all right so
that's hugely disappointing that's
working out that way but nonetheless I
will I will continue on we do have
screenshots for most of it so the other
important thing is that this yeah let's
just kill that because that's just way
too annoying so again it's really
important that you likely to be using
this phone this app outside in direct
sunlight when you're in a hurry so you
really don't want to have to read small
text and hit small touch target so you
want everything to be as simple and easy
to use as possible and basically
everything in the app goes along those
lines it's really simple to use really
straightforward to be able to to select
different elements within the UI which
is great well it seems that our
technical difficulties have scared off
most people which is a shame but
nonetheless so that's basically how
everything goes one of the nice touches
as well that we had and if we if I drop
back to to this screen you'll see up the
top there is in fact a little menu item
or a little action item I should say
which is going to allow you to just
start a music player now in this case
it's going to start up Google music now
one of the really nice things about this
is that you can do this in your app and
this is this makes a lot of sense right
because a lot of the times when you are
going to be using an app like this it's
going to be while you're exercising
you're going to want to listen to music
this is pretty common so having a quick
link to music player is is a really
useful a really nice touch and you can
do this by creating an intent to launch
a music player like this note that it's
it's changed
lightly an ice-cream sandwich and you
can see both of the options on screen
here now note that this doesn't
specifically launch a Google music the
launch intent doesn't specify a
particular music player any app that's
capable of playing browsing or
manipulating music fast assault on the
device can specify the category app
music in its manifest and be presented
as an option when this intent is fired
so if you're building a music player
that's something you may want to
consider when building your app now
let's take a look at the next app that I
installed which is RunKeeper from
fitness keeper now they've taken the
approach of using their feature graphic
to display their app name and logo now
it's perfectly reasonable but it lacks
the punch of something more
representative of their brand rather
than just the branding itself now the
biggest roadblock for me was the five
touches it took to get from my launcher
to the main screen now that's a lot of
work to do to get to the point where I
can decide if I even want to use the app
now when I did get to the homescreen I
felt a little like I've walked into a
time warp with old style tabs and a
title bar now in fairness it turns out
that RunKeeper has a new beta so I'm
going to switch to that which hopefully
I took a screenshot off but I'd parently
didn't now their new design is
definitely more modern it's very much
the same navigation as you can see here
but they've replaced the the tabs with a
view page of style tab pager they've got
an action bar now unfortunately it looks
like a view page if it doesn't swipe so
that's one of the most important things
that they need to do to create that
consistency is make sure that they can
swipe between tabs and that's kind of
the the story for their entire redesign
is that it's not really a change in the
app it's it's just cosmetic so I would
you know definitely suggest that they
take this opportunity to rethink some of
the navigation some of the structure of
the app as well as just the the raw
cosmetics so because at the moment the
layout of navigation is pretty much
unchanged and in terms of data and
functionality provided on the main
screen it's actually pretty simple
similar to what endomondo has with a
couple of really important differences
now before I start exercising there's no
indication of what information I'll get
will it be mapped will be recorded
we'll be recording the time or distance
I really don't see any of that before I
get started and that really makes me
reluctant to to to get started in my
exercise knowing that I I really don't
know what's going to happen how much of
what I want to be recorded is going to
be and a lot of users are like me and
will understand their bill install a
bunch of options all at once before
jumping in and seeing what each has to
offer so as a result it's important that
you give potential users as clear a
picture of what you offer without them
having to do anything now they've also
put a lot of emphasis on how I'm
receiving my location and the input type
is the first thing I'm presented with
and 99% of the time there's going to be
GPS and probably consolidated with Wi-Fi
and cell ID if that's accurate enough in
practice for an app like this you're
going to want to listen to every
location update that comes through using
a pattern a lot like this one as
described in the location strategies API
guide section maintaining a current best
estimate this is going to let you listen
for updates from every location source
after which you can determine the most
likely current position this is really
important for apps like these we're a
few small offsets for a few sort of
small seconds can turn a 10-mile jog
into 100-mile Odyssey you know what I
mean you've all seen someone's hilarious
social media post with a massive spike
in distance where the appear to have
jogged across a river or up a mountain
rage thanks to some GPS reflection error
so don't be the punchline to a joke try
and sanity check all of your location
results so that your users are able to
get the best possible location at any
given time now otherwise the app works
in much the same way you hit start stop
one of the strange thing is is once you
hit stop you get prompted as to whether
or not you want to save your results so
that should be given you should always
save anything the users does and give
them an option to you know to delete
something rather than an option to save
it the other thing I noticed is that
they have map pins which looks
strikingly similar to the ones in iOS
which in and of itself isn't a problem
except that it looks a little bit weird
on an Android device to have these these
pins which look like they come from a
differ
operating system one good piece of news
for this app which I really liked is
that it does send everything to a server
without you having to log in now logging
into the other apps was actually a real
hassle it took a lot of time and effort
having to exchange credentials create
accounts and email addresses all this
sort of stuff whereas here it Auto syncs
without me having to do anything which
is actually a really nice touch now
while I was navigating around this app
actually noticed a couple of strange
artifacts and one is the way that they
they're using a webview to present a lot
of their screens and that in and of
itself is perfectly fine there's there's
no problem with that but the
implementation of the way that they've
done it is making the zoom controls
become visible at various times now you
can make sure that you turn off both the
built-in zoom controls and the
visibility of the on screen zoom you
know the the ability to pinch zoom as
well as the ability to zoom using the
controls by turning off the zoom
controls that should be enough to make
it all go away
but if you hit both of these methods
here then that will definitely make sure
that there are no ability for the user
to zoom on a display which you know
you've clearly designed not to zoom
another strange artifact is this modal
dialog that tells me that my GPS result
is pretty crappy now I don't want to see
this
unless it's preventing the app from
being able to do what it needs to do so
you really don't want to pop it up
unless I've already hit the start button
and definitely not randomly while I'm
just navigating the app now last but
certainly not least let's take a look at
runtastic now leaving the strange
capitalization choices that they've made
aside they've got a pretty good landing
page on Google Play like endomondo
they've used a feature graphic that
immediately makes you feel like you
understand the purpose of the product
and the sorts of people that they're
marketing towards and they're low gaan
logo and icon is pretty good but i would
really love to see them lose that
rounded rectangle and choose a more
distinctive silhouette and you know if
you kind of look at it you can see that
you know maybe even as simple as
removing the blue so you've just got the
running man on the black ribbon would
look kind of Awesome and definitely
distinctive so that's something that you
guys may want to consider now once we
get to the main screen we can see that
it
actually pretty similar to endomondo
which is great you know clearly there is
a best practice here which I think a lot
of these apps are going to move towards
straight away we can see what we'll be
recording and there's a big green button
to let me know to get started and as a
bonus runtastic also displays details
like the sunrise sunset time the current
weather forecast temperature all of
which is a really nice bonus and in fact
those extra details are also included in
my workout data so I can see whether it
was sunny cloudy hot cold as I did each
workout which i think is a really nice
touch and provides a little bit more
context for your daily workout and
they've included them on screen here in
a way that isn't overly intrusive which
is always a nice touch so the
functionality provided on the main page
is really similar but they've made a
couple of specific design choices which
I think risks users falling into the you
know you're holding it wrong trap which
is something you always want to avoid so
the main thing you'll notice here is
that there's no obvious indication of
what your touch targets are and in fact
as soon as I started touching things on
the screen I tended to get it wrong so
I'd hit each of the different like
duration time things to try and get like
pace or calories or anything like that
and nothing happened and so it's not
until you try and hitch the the smallest
touch target on the entire UI the tiny
cog in the middle that you get that
functionality you hit that and then
you're able to modify them and again
what that does is pops up a really
really small bar which of icons which
lets you choose which of the different
you know settings that you want to view
so again it's tiny tiny touch targets
which don't tell you that they are and
this can be a real problem because I'm
using this app while I'm stretching
while I'm you know jogging preparing to
to start my exercise regime you really
want to have things be big easy to touch
and obvious to know what you're going to
touch and it's kind of the same thing
here once you get down to the workout
type and activity type you know it's not
obvious that their buttons you click on
them and it pops up a dialog with small
text in you
closely-spaced and you really want to
and you really want to make sure that
that's easy for people to use and easy
for people to navigate and it's the same
with the Big Green Go button it's
clearly a button but it's not actually
an Android button so all of these things
taken together it really puts you in a
situation where you're having to think
before you can use the app having to
figure out how do I get it to do the
things that I wanted to do and for an
app like this where you want people to
be able to get started quickly and
easily that can be a real problem so
once we get going
they've again made a really interesting
choice and unfortunately I can't show it
to you right now but once you start your
workout you actually have to unlock the
screen before you're able to do anything
and in fact if you don't so if you just
try and hit the pause or stop button on
your workout you get a toast that pops
up saying you're doing it wrong
you know you have to unlock the screen
first now I didn't even notice
excuse me I didn't even notice that the
first time that I went to stop a workout
I just hit stop turned off the screen
and when I opened up the app later on I
noticed that it was still going now a
good tip for you works in general is
that if you're using a toast to tell
your users that they should have done
something else when they did what they
did you're probably one doing it wrong
rather than them so it's really
important to figure out how users are
actually using your app and make sure
that you optimize for that in this case
they've made the assumption that the
most likely thing that may happen is a
user will accidentally stop something on
the screen now the most users chances
are they will just turn the screen off
when they don't want to touch anything
so they're better off relying on the
phone then having something built into
your app
okay so once we finish the workout the
experience is pretty great from this
point onwards I probably prefer
runtastic to endomondo the contextual
information you get around things like
weather relative speed the way that they
display your speed along your track on
the map is really great though
there is an option there to choose
between save and done once you finished
a workout which is a little bit
confusing as I said before saving should
have already happened it should just be
a case of yes I finished reviewing this
let me go back to the main screen and
another comment I had is that their
settings screen is really complex again
you sort of in this pattern of having to
really read a lot of text to figure out
how to do stuff which is something you
should try and avoid in apps like this
now the next few points apply to more
than just round tap or just round
runtastic so I want to make sure that
that the shame gets applied broadly and
the credit where it's due as well but I
think what we're trying to focus on here
on the app clinic is ways that you can
improve your app so we're gonna try and
highlight a couple of the things which
could be done perhaps a little bit
better now
first off both fantastic and endomondo
have a little surprise waiting in their
overflow menu it is in fact an exit
button now those of you who know me know
that my initial reaction to seeing an
exit button is something a lot like this
I chose not to destroy our studio room
once again to make a point and in fact
you can find my full thoughts on exit
buttons in Android apps and why they
shouldn't exist by watching tableflip on
YouTube where I lay out exactly why this
app anti-pattern fills me with an
impenetrable darkness but in some ways I
guess I get it these apps represent kind
of a special case they should definitely
keep running while they're in the
background and they all do use
notifications to let us know that that's
exactly what's happening so given that
they have two choices to figure out what
the right use case is both of them
involve getting rid of something called
exit so need to decide if they're more
like turn-by-turn navigation or if
they're more like a music player after
the sake of argument I'm going to say
that they should be more like music
players which which really means that I
only want to see a notification
I only want to have the app continue to
run in the background while I'm doing a
workout so as soon as I hit play or
start then by all means pop up the
notification start an ongoing service
make sure that the app doesn't go away
but then as soon as I hit stop as soon
as my workout is finished then I want
the app to behave just as any other app
so hitting home or hitting back out of
the app should take it out of memory
should stop GPS updates and just
basically give me my phone back as
though the app was never running at the
moment you have this tendency of like
I've just opened the app checked it out
hit home and I have this icon saying or
this notification saying hey actually
it's still running and that's not a
great user experience I don't want to
have to figure out how to make it stop I
already did make it stop by ending my
workout while we're talking about
notifications I think there's really a
fantastic opportunity to make these
notifications even more useful now at
the moment all three of the apps have a
simple click here to return to the app
text within their notification and why
not be a little bit more adventurous I'd
love to see rich notifications with the
actions that let me pause or end my
workout directly from the notification
shade and I'd also love to see some more
details on my workout here
things like duration distance traveled
basically anything that I've selected to
look out on the app home screen why not
stick it in the notification as well I
think that really will present a really
rich experience for your users in fact
when we look to stopwatch apps just a
few weeks ago we saw a few examples of
rich unit notifications being used to
great effect where you could basically
use the entire stopwatch app without
actually having to launch the app the
other thing missing from all three apps
was a tablet layout in fact only
RunKeeper even supported the option of
using the app in landscape mode now I
know that these apps were originally
created with the thought of having a
fitness companion on your phone I'm sure
no one really imagined strapping a Nexus
7 to your arm as you go jogging but what
about if you're using it at the gym or
if you're using it rowing then suddenly
a tablet isn't quite as ridiculous an
option now step one is creating a great
responsive design that means that the
app will work great on whatever device I
happen to be using no matter what the
orientation or screen size
so that's where I'd start really just
make sure that I can use the app in a
way that doesn't frustrate me on a
tablet device step two is creating a
great tablet specific experience now
even if I'm not planning to take my
Nexus 10 growing I'd love to go through
my workouts while I'm sitting on my
couch not working out whether that's
reviewing the tracks I've run analyzing
the data sort of doing all that stuff to
figure out what is my fitness level all
of that stuff will be fantastic to do
directly on a tablet and in fact that's
one of the things that mint.com
discovered them when they created an
optimized tablet experience it turns out
that tablet users are more deeply
engaged and more likely to spend time
within the app so mint responded by
creating a richer experience
specifically for tablet users designed
around data analysis rather than data
entry so where is on the mint phone app
you'd go through and actually put in all
of your purchase keep track of your
budget within the tablet app you would
be able to go through and see exactly
where you'd been spending money and do
that deep analysis and I think that
there's really an opportunity to these
apps to do something similar to drive
their user engagement and really get
people addicted to their service so
before we sign off let's take a quick
look at the prescriptions that we have
for each app to help them move towards a
pure Android experience so we'll start
off with in demondo so first off kill
the exit button it should keep running
only while we're tracking a workout
they've actually got kind of a bug so I
made a note to say that they have an
issue with their navigation drop-down
list on their home page where that it
doesn't have a drop-down icon to tell
you it's a list now as it happens that
doesn't seem to be the case on all
devices so that's just a bug to take a
look at similarly the settings that
you've got within the navigation
drop-down should be in the overflow menu
rather than within the activities you
know within the main activities
navigation know table of view force
portrait please don't ever force
portrait mode I would like to use my
tablet in landscape mode and as soon as
you lock it to portrait I feel like
you're basically saying you can't use
this app on the device that you're using
that's a 7 Meg download I'm not entirely
sure why it's
and make download that seems like a lot
for what the app is doing so maybe
consider what you're packaging in there
and how many of those assets you need to
have on the device in terms of runtastic
Pro 10 Meg downloads seriously why are
these apps so big it feels like you
could drop a lot of that without having
to lose a lot of the assets that you're
using the fact that it takes five clicks
to get to the to the beginning of the
app the first time you run it is a real
turnoff you know every time I have to
click the button again and that much
more attempted to just hit back go to
the Play Store and download something
faster you want to update your UI a
little bit there's some iPhone II
looking buttons which just kind of look
out a place on Android and same exit
button same as same as endomondo please
get rid of the exit button the settings
screen and the overall UI isn't as
intuitive as it could be I mean it's a
great app it has a lot of the features
that I really want to see just feels
like I have to do a bit too much work to
be able to use it build the tablet mode
would be fantastic again don't lock me
into portrait if you don't have to and
yeah maybe see if you can do something
about the logo I think you like 90% of
the way there was something awesome you
could just get rid of the rounded
corners and suddenly you've got
something which would be a really
distinctive and really great Android
logo and finally RunKeeper
so here you know it's great to see that
you guys are doing a UI overall overhaul
to bring in some of those new patterns
like action bar I definitely think it's
an opportunity for you to maybe look a
little bit more deeply into the
structure of the app in the navigation
but it's definitely heading along the
right path so keep that up do get rid of
that modal dialogue for missing location
that that is just death and the menu
button of shame which is actually a
full-blown menu button of shame clicking
it does nothing so make sure that that
goes away as part of your redesign also
takes like three or four clicks to go
from opening the app to being able to do
anything so again try and speed up that
that first user flow from downloading it
from Google Play and running it the
first time should be as quick as
possible
so that's all for us today apologies for
the technical snafus which meant we
couldn't do any of the the live stuff
but I think hopefully we were able to
share most of the information that we
intended to don't forget to tune in to
Roman Nick and Adam for Android design
in action on Tuesday where they'll be
sending their design skills loose on
some of the apps that we looked at today
hopefully there will be no app clinic
next week it's celebrating turkey day
here in the US and we're going to be
spending some time trying to find and
rescue in from the backwoods hopefully
with the minimum number of his limbs
sawn off with a pocket knife when we're
back device profile apps will be up on
the table we'll be looking at apps like
Tasker and NFC task launcher so if
you've got a device profile app that
you'd like us to take a look at be sure
to hit our Trello page at bitly slash
app clinic Trello and get your votes and
nominations in I want to quickly throw a
question over to Dan find out if there
are any questions or comments from folks
on any of the feeds which which need to
be responded to so we have two questions
the first one is how what's the best way
to integrate social aspects into these
types of apps good and I'll ask the
second one later sure so that's actually
a good question in something which I
didn't touch on but at least two of the
apps endomondo and runtastic both have
deep integration with social features
now they've done it a pretty good way
and you can see that a lot of people
will share their workouts via things
like Facebook and Twitter and likewise
endomondo has the has the ability to
actually cheer your friends on or
compete against them I think these are
all really rich uses of social using
your social circles it's been proven in
fact that with things like anything
goal-setting particularly things like
exercise having people hold you
accountable is a really great way of
being able to help motivate you and keep
your willpower up so I think the key to
social integration here on a
philosophical level is to find ways to
help you be accountable to your friends
and create something you know
competitive with people which is always
a real help when it comes to things like
fitness in terms of practical
implementation details I think the key
is really to try and make it as smooth
the past as possible so whatever social
network you're choosing to integrate
with you want to make sure that that
sign-in flow is as smooth as possible
like I said I actually had some trouble
creating account on endomondo and I want
this to be as much of a one-click
process as possible so whether that's
signing in to Facebook Twitter G+ or
anything else which you know provides
you with some of the functionality you
need you don't really want to try and
make that process as smooth as possible
and ideally make sure it doesn't block
so I want to be able to use the app with
no social features and with no account
and then see the reasons why you know
cooking this into my social network
would be beneficial and then once you've
done that you want to make sure as well
that you're not doing anything obnoxious
you know make sure that you always give
the users an option as to whether they
want to share something on their social
network or not and in fact one of the
apps I believe it was runtastic has a
share icon but it doesn't actually let
you share anything unless you're logged
in and that's something you want to
avoid as well you know it's great to
have the social features built in
directly to those websites if you can
just to lower the friction but even if I
haven't chosen to sign in with Facebook
I still want to be able to share it
using any of the apps that I have
installed which may include things like
Facebook Twitter or G+ so you want to
make sure that you don't limit yourself
just to those tight integrations and
make sure that just standard sharing
across you know regular Android
intent-based sharing works as well cool
and the last question that we have is
have any of the apps that we've reviewed
that on the app clinic made it appear
Android yet so good news on that we have
been spending some time going through
the apps which we have looked at and we
have looked at a lot of apps over the
last year so it's taken us a bit of time
but we have I think two or three
candidates which we're just going
through now within the team to make sure
that we're all satisfied with and we'll
hopefully have something to announce in
the week after Thanksgiving so not this
week but the week after will hopefully
be inducting the first of our apps into
the pure Android app clinic collection
all right so thank you very much for
watching everyone that's all we've got
time for today join us in a couple of
weeks for the next episode of the act
clinic until then I'm reto Meier and
this has been the app clinic thank you
for watching